[Music]
what's up everybody it is monday morning
fresh off the b day weekend thanks for
all the lovely b-day wishes your boy's
getting older it is what it is man still
the youngest of my crew though still the
young buck still
wet behind the ears when it comes to my
friends i'm still the youngest so that's
fantastic
uh yeah but thank you for all the b-day
wishes let's get to work baby because uh
man
we had one hell of a freaking ufc card
this past saturday
um
i told you guys i've said this uh
right when the ufc announced it
you know london come off this whole
covid lockdown just like all of us but
london especially was pretty locked down
when they announced that they were gonna
do this card i thought it was gonna be a
pay-per-view thank god it wasn't so
everybody could watch it but
just the uh
the card from top to bottom man uh to me
as literally from the first fight on the
prelims to the last fight on the main
card with tom aspinall it was the most
stat card from top to bottom maybe not
the biggest names in north america but
as far as outside north america dude you
it's for european fighting especially
england london the uk in general you
have the who's who on this
you know you're missing darren till on
there but outside that you had all the
big boys on this card and i was uh i was
super excited for it man
and what's interesting too is i didn't
think this card got enough
notoriety i didn't see enough people
talking about it there and i'm sure in
london it was completely different but
out here
a lot of times i'll gauge a card kind of
hype based off just casual people
whether i'm at a coffee shop or my
friends or dude i'm talking nothing
nothing i was surprised by it uh you
know sometimes you engage your cards
interest off
the ufc when they post the you know the
hype videos or the countdowns or the
you know the the breakdowns of the fight
or even on uh bt sport with uh bisping
and the the boys on there who i think do
the best job uh out there as far as
covering fights especially when it comes
to uh the uk
but even their numbers weren't like
gangbusters i just couldn't understand
it um
and you know it was a big fight card
because we did a calabasas fight
campaign for it we really only do
pay-per-views man that's what we do but
i was such a
kind of
just so excited for this card man for a
number of reasons so so excited
and if you missed out on it i would go
back and watch it not only would i watch
the card from top to bottom i'd watch
the cowboys fight companion as well it
was a grand old time with jeff dye and
crystalia who aren't you know
fight experts but they really got into
it man and i don't know how you couldn't
with uh you know
there's a reason michael bisping was
undefeated in uh
on his home soil man i i really think
it's one of the rare places i don't
think there's anybody there's anywhere
else
in the world that just feeds off the
energy and the fan base and the the
whole history of the fight culture uh
like they do in england man i just don't
and you can see the fighters when they
walk out they just
they just kind of soak up all that
craziness and they take it into the
octagon and you know
dana gave every single person who got a
finish a bonus every single person now i
did they give my boy jack shore a bonus
they didn't because they didn't get a
finish which is
kind of robbery
it was a fantastic fight jack shore uh
will definitely be ranked the top 15 now
now that
he wasn't before it's insane but shout
out to jack shore uh completely i
thought stole the show on the prelims it
just shows you how goddamn well rand
rounded jack shore is he's so freaking
talented
hopefully from now on he's at least at
least the main event on the prelims but
should definitely be on the main card he
got a real one at bantamweight and jack
shore just uh just a great dude and
skills are unreal dude unreal
uh then we get to the main card again
this o2 arena
you know they blew the roof off this
thing they blew it off uh jaw herbert
you know obviously didn't go his way he
got knocked out pretty bad um
but you i you know that knockout was bad
but really for me the card really
started with meatball molly mccain you
know she uh is a crowd favorite out
there uh training partner with patty
pinblet and so uh she i don't know what
they have in the water in their hometown
with patty and molly but jesus christ we
need to bottle that energy up that
positivity that energy that you know
gift of the gab just the the happiness
if if if fiji could just quit making
water from the fiji mountains and bottle
the water up where patty and molly are
from we would have a real business there
because those two men uh i thought stole
the show
uh you know it and listen i always like
to give the mvp of the card
yeah i don't know how you do it then
to be fair that's why dana gave
everybody you gotta finish a freaking
bonus it was just
from start to finish man gangbusters
gangbusters i hope more people see
what's going on here man but this was a
if you didn't know now you know it's a
coming out party uh for england in the
uk man they got some real talent out
there and uh you know molly meatball
dude a spinning back elbow
nazos
nazos great knockout
definitely top five not knockout
candidates of the year
not so you never see that women's
flyweight
nuts
um her energy was contagious man
so you go from that the crowd's going
nuts she jumps in the crowd very jose
aldo's style she grabs dana you know
she's doing her thing you can't help but
fall in love with meatball and also
meatball great name we have a meatball
here i think we should change his name
after seeing molly molly's the real
meatball
and they you told me chin on the
companion they call her meatball because
you used to sell meatballs
i don't really say that someone else
said someone else said that
that's what it was she used to work out
she used to make foot longs and then
like that
you know to be fair though
when i was uh back in my fat days i
would go to subway and the only thing
you get is that meatball that meatball's
so good there
yeah you might get today here's it now
here's the thing casey i like where your
hat's at i like that i like that
is it real meat probably not
awesome still good whatever it is
because they they got in trouble for
their tuna remember we found out
you know yeah and then they're like then
yeah then subways trying to do damage
control they're like that's a false
narrative it's real tuna and then like a
real lab god i was like
no it's not tuna this is actually made
out of um plastic so it's flavored
plastic everybody i i mean you go to a
subway and get the tuna freaking melt or
whatever you just you just play with
fire man you know there's a better place
to get tuna
it ain't subway yeah somebody's had
their you know i hate to go on a
roundabout subway here but they've uh
you know
they
they they're marketing right started
with jared from subway
um theo did go on a date with his sister
that is facts he went on a date with uh
jeer from subway's sister it didn't work
out surprisingly um
but then you know jared was the big guy
got world famous because he just ate
subway sandwiches supposedly i guess
we'll buy that and then he lost a
gillion pounds i think i don't know he
was like 400 pounds or 300 pounds and
then got down
you know and then he was the face of
subway and he was basically the oprah of
subway and then you know he did some
badges he did some bad stuff with kids
and then he is gone
he is gone and subway went yowzers
yowzers
so let's create a catchy phrase here
five to five dollar
five dollar foot longs remember that
that was lit and then then we found out
you know they had another marketing
blender that their tuna was plastic
so they're trying their best man i think
molly should be sponsored by subway
you're looking for a fresh face that's
their thing fresh fresh bread fresh
faces molly's a subway alumni
you know she has all the energy
come up with the molly you know
six six inch sub meatballs up yeah the
molly the molly how they don't do their
home town is insane
how's subway's not knocking down her
doors insane when's the last time subway
had
good news
you know that jared stuff's just hanging
over their head man and molly completely
changed that just spitballing ideas
subway i don't know what's going on with
your business plan these days i also
don't know anybody who eats subway
except for casey i'm gonna meet paul
today and i hope you get sick from it
uh our boy gunner nelson who we always
root for got a win he needed that
that was the only kind of
you know it wasn't a bad fight it was
the only like not knock your dick in the
ground fight the rest of them will blow
your hair back
um
so it was like it was molly the crowd
went freaking nutsos when herbert lost
the crowd was sad right because he's
english so he got knocked out pretty bad
really bad so they're pretty quiet um
and then molly comes out and spinning
elbow the crowd goes nuts she's a fan
favorite gutter nelson comes out with
sat though it's a decision not a
terrible fight 30 26 across the board
gunner nelson dominated had his back
literally for about 40 years
and then uh
you know really
the face of the card the the fresh face
i keep this the third time said fresh
face i've never said it on the show
before but really the fresh face
the the new wave
of england england fighting the
the next in line to kind of
be maybe their conor mcgregor patty
pimplet was up
and
you know last week if you listen to the
show i went you know is the moment too
big for him and you know he's the one
you know kind of x factor then also same
with tom aspinall is you know he's a
coveted baby he's been in mass he's
fought in front of seven people even
though he's starching dudes he's never
felt that kind of real ufc
jitters uh debut
you know it is you know no matter what
uh it can be stressful fighting the ufc
especially at the level of competition
he's fighting but still not the real
deal holy field where it's in front of a
crowd sure as hell not in front of a
home crowd o2 arena the blue
the roof blew off the goddamn place
patty's an interesting one
i should put some more thought into it
as i was talking last week you know
what's interesting about patty is before
he was in the ufc he was a star a
massive massive star
and the ufc has been trying to sign him
for quite some time and god bless this
kid to have the wits to go i'm not ready
yet i'm going to wait
but patty could have sold this thing out
himself that's what's so crazy
that being said i still was worried
about you know fighting you know at the
arena even though he's fought in big
venues before and could sell this thing
out himself it's still not a ufc
and until you're in the ufc it's just a
different animal whether you know he
could sell out you know the same arenas
that anything joshua's selling out you
know any of that stuff that's all fine
and denny but it's still not the ufc
it's just it's just a different animal
and that was the one thing i was not
worried just had questions about i was a
little curious
so when patty walks out you realize who
the ultimate kind of alpha male is as
far as star power goes on this card and
that arena was
notzos
nutsos and this kid you know it shows
you know
same when conor was coming up he just
has that x factor where the moment can't
get big enough for him he thinks
you know this is
exactly what he should be doing he's the
exact situation walking down that the
exact path that he planned for himself
and boy you know
is he fighting a top 10 guy no should he
be no absolutely not but you know at
lightweight which is stacked at 55 you
know vargas is no punk it you know it's
it's not an easy road to get to the ufc
the guy's there it's like a mack truck
and you know for for patty along with
his first fight you know he gets hit
he does get hit it makes it more
exciting but um
the only literally the only kind of
if you're going to check you know a
negative on it is you know there's two
fights nfc has been hit
he has taken some hits and that scares
you a little bit um
you know if you're going to compare
compare him to conor mcgregor i'll say
stand-up's not as good as chris as conor
mcgregor's connor really wasn't getting
hit you know but
how do you get hit
i think it's his style i think you know
it's it's an experience i think he's
excited and um
it could be a problem but you know his
team i'm sure is realizing the same
thing
everybody listen to this show as well
and saw the fight go he gets hit man a
little bit you know if if they keep you
know and it is it's like a video game
the next level gets harder harder harder
you're getting a certain point where you
can't get hit like that you know but
still early still dominating got got the
guy down i think anybody that uh
is a paddy fan knew that this fight he
was gonna have a significant event
advantage on the ground and it showed um
you know as good as his striking is
enough he landed that flying knee in his
first fight and got the job down
got the job done but um
he's pretty special on the ground it
goes to the ground you know guys are
getting mopped up so for him to get a
finish
you know fight no two arena pretty big
deal man
i think people saw his star power and
you know when he gets done he gets on
the mic he rips a pretty good promo and
he just again just has that
justin bieber you know that that kind of
thing that we want to watch man and uh
there's a lot i i i it doesn't seem like
it gets to him again he checks all the
boxes when it comes to marketing and
skill set and all that stuff so the ufc
is going to attach that
british rocket on his back that they did
with uh michael bisping and see what
happens and you know if he was a stock i
would definitely invest i actually have
my reservations as far as you know him
getting hit a little bit that's a little
alarming but it's also very exciting um
but he's a special special kid man
there's a reason barstool signed him
this seven figure deal
you know so i'm curious if barstool did
a bunch of content with them i'm sure if
you put money in anything but yeah
really yeah lead them to the fighter and
see anything but man
damn man i'd be all over them yeah they
didn't do shirts or anything nothing
nothing that i saw ooh
baby little shirts for patty yeah
um
yeah but i i think uh
you know he's he's passing the test it's
gonna be interesting to see what they do
for him next
you know it's just where he's at
you know
then the ufc has gotten a lot better
about this is you know with sugar shawn
o'malley
and i i think dana said this in the post
fight press conference he goes you know
it's similar with the sugar shot
o'malley kind of path there where you
don't want to just rush the guy to the
front of the line especially at 55 man
especially at 55.
oh there there's a there's a shirt
patty the baddie shirt
dave porter and that's the bar stools
man i might have to order that
they have it on their site jen
yeah cause i mean barstool they're smart
they're definitely smarter than me they
uh
they know what's going on as far as that
stuff you said you got a seven figure
deal
paddy's irish
[Music]
pub oh it's got to be right
they have more than that though right
if you type in uh
all these stuff caller daddy merch on
there good for them
if you just type in patty does anything
coming up just that stuff so i typed in
his name and nothing
uh type in just patty and see what
happens nice last name
that's what happened it was just this
stuff
um
[Music]
that's it huh yeah
man
that shirt's all right
it's really hoping for something better
i can lie to you man
maybe it's in the plans
i'm sure
uh but what's this this is just this bar
still posting about maddie's let me see
bar still go nut react to it because you
gotta figure barstool again it's
investment for them this guy loses it's
tough man especially this early on
this is them
that's big cat and uh
fortnite
[Applause]
coaching
he's probably like dear god please when
we got a bunch of money
that's great i love it
i love the show
yeah they act like it wasn't a minus 675
favorite though you know but when you
got investment in there
fastest face time of all time let me see
that
yeah because barstow and ufc are in
cahoots together so i'm sure the ufc let
them know you know like
just a picture this is the guy you want
to ride with you know
[Music]
i just did a picture of a picture yeah
that's hilarious that's great
yeah patty passed the test blew the roof
off of o2 arena and then uh you know
it's tough to give anybody mvp but you
know because there's a few that's the
reason why dana gave everybody the bonus
so you know molly meatball he had a
patty pimplet obviously deserves it and
then the co-main event
they had a tough gig man because you're
following patty you're following patty
all the energy went into the paddy's
performance you know he jumps on the
cage meatball jumped on the cage as well
you know she was all over the place
so the arena's going nuts and then you
got to reset and then arnold allen and
dan hooker walks out and you know it's a
great fight but there's just kind of you
know you can only
rev it at uh
so many rpms for so long before you got
to reset and they reset so arnold allen
dan hooker you know if they would have i
think if this would have been anywhere
else i don't think arnold allen fights
this way
you know but coming off the the patty
pimplet fight
you know he he had to put on a show
and
he definitely put on a show
you know you fighting dan hooker and
that you know i was reading about dan
hook you're saying how terrible the
weight cut was saying was awful said if
i would have fought at 55 drunk i would
have had a better performance he said
the weight cut was absolutely horrendous
it's tough because dan hooker's one of
my favorites he's one of my favorite
people great dad you know he's had his
issues coming from new zealand australia
trying to get all these fights being
quarantined and away from his family and
he's kind of the
you know the uh the down under donald
cerrone where he'll take any fight any
time and even though he's flying 16
hours to the state so show up and fight
you so
you know he's a he's a fighters fighter
man and i love the guy he has skills
it's just you know the the 45 weight cut
they thought he was gonna have a big
advantage there
you know but arnold allen with his
genetics and his family you know being
strong men [ __ ] like that you're dealing
with a different animal he's also won
nine in a row now dude which is insane
so
i get you know dan hooker obviously he
was i think he's number six at
lightweight coming down to 45.
i get all that
and also when you look at hooker he's
not actually exactly known to
blow your hair back as far as like put
on crazy performances
again
this british crowd man brings out the
best in everybody and forces you to kind
of
get out of your comfort zone and you you
got to live up to the hype and you're
falling a patty pimplet so what's arnold
allen do dude these boys just started
swaying in men it was for sure fight of
the night they would have got a bonus no
matter what dana decided to do but it's
definitely fight of the night and man
i'm you know my heart sinks for dan
hooker but you know just it was a tough
night in the office fighting in no two
arena against arnold allen who's won at
this point eight in a row
and also i don't think dan hooker
expected him to come out like this it's
not really in arnold allen's
kind of dna to fight like this it's not
but um god dang that fight was nuts
nazos by far won the best rounds of the
year
by far one of the best rounds of the
year
so
molly blows the roof off gunner you know
decision all good dominates so you got
molly the meatball mccann blown the roof
off subway's finest gunner does his
thing then you have paddy pimlet
does exactly what we all thought he was
gonna do the the main draw of the card
blows the [ __ ] roof off and they're
like all right there's gonna be a let
down here then arnold allen goes hold my
guinness comes out does the freaking
thing rocks the freaking arena and then
you're still not even at the main event
yet and you got tom aspinall versus
volkov and volkov is damn near
impossible to finish i think out of he
has like 40 freaking fights he's only
been finished i think three times in his
career he's fought the who's who
uh i think by the night of the fight
leading up to it
he was a slight underdog which was kind
of crazy to me you know you're talking
about a guy went to decision with cyril
gone
beat freaking alistar over him beat walt
harris
um you know beat fabrizio verdoom beat
roy nelson
was a world champion you know uh was a
world champion and not only m1 but also
bellator so
you're talking about a real you know a
real pedigree you're talking about a
real monster man
and
to be honest i i you know i have all the
faith in tom aspen but you just don't
know
and when tom goes from
fighting guys who aren't ranked and you
know only one guy the second round but
you know he beat uh andre olofsky that's
very tough to do you know andre
arlovski's long in the tooth
so for tom aspen all to go from
kind of
not really fighting world beaters to
jumping to number six you get a little
worried you know you get a little
worried and uh
man if you're a tom aspinall fan or
again and you're investing in stocks you
would put all of your money on tom asman
become world champ after seeing this
he completely
dominated volkov more so than anybody
i've ever seen has tom has vocab been
knocked out sure dirk lewis knocked him
out you know lost to curtis blades sure
sure
nobody dominated him in every aspect of
mixed martial arts like tom aspinall
this this you know for tom aspen on he
says you know i've dreamt of this since
i was a kid i belong here sure sure i
get all that but you haven't beat
anybody in the top 15
and now you get the number six guy in
the world
it was impossible to finish and you
completely molly whop them
hand speed com light years different
lighting them up on the feet taking them
down at will and then you take them down
twice you get them down you choke them
out with a straight arm bar
he look he looks like a uh
uh a frank mayor you know part two
he looks like a
uh a hybrid frank mayor man the guy
looked [ __ ] phenomenal
and after watching that fight when he
did the volkov
think about volkov man decision was
cyril gone
you know went to disintercede gone
so
you know i think tom asmal is gonna be
ranked top four at this point
and he got on the mic and did exactly uh
what he should have done
he gets on the mic and kind of calls his
shot which i don't think is really tom
espinal's thing i do think it helps that
bisping's in there because you know
bisping would call guys out and
bisping's also a guy who you know if
it's john addick or rogan they don't
really go you know what's next who do
you want not really this mean anybody
come on man who's next what's next for
you and he it it's not like he's
pressuring him but it's also like you
gotta answer the question you feel some
type of way which i think he's the
perfect guy for the job especially at
though to arena with his legacy there he
did a great job so with tom aspinall
it's like what's next and tom had a plan
tom had a plan he called out tai tuavasa
my head i'm like ooh that's a fun one i
think tai is number three now
and you look at the division you you
know you got stipe jon jones francis had
surgery so france is out nine months
so stipe and jon jones that's the fight
that i think happens this summer
who's next tied to avasa
i mean you could have been like well
let's see if chris blades gets past you
know homeboy on uh saturday and uh would
say
yeah let's see if he gets past philly's
finest darkest on saturday if he does
i'd be interested in curtis blades but
that you know don't get me wrong i'd
love to see tom vs uh curtis blades
because i do think tom provides a number
of issues for curtis blades
but as far as just pure entertainment
and to get tom to title shot
it's a great move to call out tied to
avasa and kind of jump that front of the
line
it's it's a great move just to jump up
there you get tied to
avasa i love i absolutely love tai
tuvavasa he's one of my favorite people
i've had on the show i've done a showy
with him we order his shoe hey thai two
of us the the the shipping bubba yeah we
ordered it
three weeks ago until a long time three
weeks ago ty what are we doing here dude
a little customer service man it's been
three weeks bubba and supposed to come
here yeah yeah
well we're trying to
replace it with the yeezy shoe dog
so um
i love thai
when i look at that fight you know i
know ty beat derrick lewis it's a great
win for him that was ty's kind of jump
into the upper echelon
but after seeing what tom aspinall did
to volkov which nobody's been able to do
nobody completely dominate them
you know i would assume ty would be a a
underdog a you know probably a plus 200
plus 225 underdog against tom aspinall
and when you look at tom and his
footwork and his hand speed and his
wrestling and his ground game
you guys cyril gone you know i i like
his chance to encirogan even man i know
it's insane to say
you know but i'd love to see john
verstipe and then tom's right there then
boy could england use a heavyweight
champ they've never had one they've
never had one in the ufc he'd be the guy
let's take a little break guys from
chatting on the shop show we have a very
special guest in john anik coming right
up before we chat with my brother from a
more bald mother
john anik i got something to talk to you
guys about this episode of the shop show
is sponsored by better help that's
better help h-e-l-p
because listen maybe there's something
interfering with your happiness it's
preventing you from achieving your goals
that you have for yourself and you just
can't get out of your own way you don't
know what's going on man you're just not
happy well that's where better help can
help your booty out they will assess
your needs and match you with your own
license professional therapist
because you need professional help man
you can only get so much advice from
your friends and family they're not
professionals
if you can get your car fixed you want
your buddy fixing who has no idea about
cars no you want to go to a professional
man it's the same thing for your
happiness talk with a professional they
know exactly what you need to do you can
start communicating under 48 hours it's
not crisis line it's not self-help it's
professional therapy done securely
online all right
this service is available worldwide
alright betterhelp is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
therapists if you're not feeling the one
that they've given you super easy to
change your therapist it's much more
affordable than traditional offline
therapy financial aid is also available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today try it out man visit
shop that's better help h-e-l-p
slash shop s-c-h-a-u-b join the over two
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using betterhelp
they're recruiting an additional
therapist in all 50 states tony it's
good stuff it's good stuff work on your
happiness work on your goals let
betterhelp help you out and they have a
special offer for the shop show
listeners and viewers you get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com shop
last commercial i promise then we're
going to jump into the juicy convo with
john anik because listen the world is
back and booming man
the cities are back your boy's on door
there's no more half capacity we're
doing it man you got back-to-back
meetings you're back to the hustle the
rat race you got errands thrown you got
chores to take care of you got kids
you're dropping off at school you're
trying to get everything done all right
you need a little help sometimes with
doordash you can get dinner household
essentials everything on your grocery
list all delivered right to your door
take the guesswork out man don't try to
pack all that in and do it yourself
doordash got you covered get what you
want
right now right to your door with
doordash along with the restaurant you
love you can now get groceries and other
central items delivered with doordash
get drinks snackies other household
items in under a freaking hour you're
craving late night ice cream all right
you forget that one key ingredient that
was gonna make this special dinner for
your family we got you man maybe you
just need to stock on up we gotcha with
doordash get everything in one app with
over 300 000 partners you can support
your neighborhood go-to's or choose from
your favorite national restaurants like
popeye's chipotle cheesecake factory
ordering is easy and your items will be
left outside your door if you choose
that all right for a limited time the
viewers and listener of the shop show
can get 25 off and zero delivery fees on
your first order of 15 bucks or more
when you download the doordash app enter
the code shop show that's 25 off up to
10 value and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download the
doordash app in the app store enter the
code shop show s-c-h-a-u-b-s-h-o-w
shop show don't forget that's code shop
show for 25 off your first order with
dordas subject to change terms apply um
so now what we're gonna do i'm gonna go
and get off the nuts of every english
fighter in the ufc
uh because we're calling uh my brother
from another mother he's one third of
the greatest
combat sports analyst team in the world
there's joe rogan there's daniel cormier
and then there's the man the glue
there's john anak and we have ufc finest
one of the greatest
commentators in the history of sports
john anik joining us right now now let's
get right into it man i i assume because
you're
a fight head like me you watch the ufc
uh london fight night
yes absolutely it's nice to have a
little matinee here on the east coast of
the u.s man those late night ufc fight
nights with the 10 p.m eastern main card
forget about it tough
man i you know going into the fight i
couldn't understand and maybe you have a
different perspective on it but
to me especially for a free card
i mean best card of the year from top to
bottom as far as matchup wise excitement
you know a few you could have called a
few fight of the nights on there i
called arnold allen and uh dan hooker
the fight of the night you know weeks
prior i just felt like
this card wasn't getting the tracks and
it should get especially for being a
free card and you watch a card literally
you know i'm a i'm a psychopath i watch
from the prelims to the main event right
and you just i mean gangbusters man that
o2 arena in london first first fight
card you know since the pandemic and man
did it live up to the hype
yeah i mean i think you set it up
beautifully and i think it was a
combination of all of those factors
right the first time being in london for
three years you had all sorts of
finishes and i think oftentimes when
people talk about card of the year
they're not looking for decisions right
so obviously you had nine finishes of
the 12 total fights and
certainly you could say it was regional
star power or european star power in
some respect but a lot of this is just
flat out ufc star power i mean when you
forecast the future for guys like arnold
allen and patty pimlet and certainly tom
aspinall whom we'll get to um these are
ufc stars whether they're competing in
london or not you know um and now
getting ready to go to columbus ohio you
know as a proud american be i'm just
hoping that uh that the ohio folks can
make some noise because that's a tough
act to follow the toughest act of fall
i love columbus ohio but i don't know if
you're gonna get the same reaction my
man i hope you do but uh i don't think
you're gonna get the same reaction uh
you know from the crowd as a you know a
molly meatball walk out or a paddock
uh patty walkout you know or even tom
askball arnold allen it was just you
know the perfect storm
are you uh are you as high and patty as
the the rest of the world do you see uh
a lot of kind of i don't know you know i
guess it's fair to say a little bit of
splash of conor mcgregor-ish you know
yeah i mean i thought michael bisping
put a well on the broadcast in so far as
he kind of carries you beginning middle
to end right he can handle all the
pre-fight stuff he's exciting as a
fighter he has a lot of finishing skills
he's a good grappler he's got a lot of
power on the feet i mean i think he's
probably number 35 in the world at
lightweight right now like how do you
think a matchup with jalen turner goes
right now for example and jalen turner
is 6'3 and not even in the top 20 right
now necessarily right so there's a lot
of work to be done for paddy pimlet but
i think he's in the best promotion in
the world to handle his matchmaking
process to handle his developmental
process you know
i'm certainly bullish on patty in terms
of his future as a ufc star and his
ability to contend um but i think my
thesis statement in terms of his
championship ceiling is that he's
probably in the wrong division competing
in his natural weight class at 155
pounds i just don't know how that's
going to happen in the next three or
four years but power to him i thought he
handled fight week beautifully and
largely that fight he handled well and
uh i'm excited for the next one as i
know the masses are as well
yeah and you know there's a thing uh
especially in our sport where
you know guys want to see
you know fans want to see these guys
fight the top 10 right away and you know
it's such a disservice to the fighter
and what i think is the ufc's kind of
learned from that you know they they
catapulted darren till to the front you
know it's been a tough go
you know so
um i do think he'll bounce back but
you know when conor was coming into it
it was just a
it was a different lay of the land you
know where patty's at 55 that's what we
did at cal bass fight companion and i
did it with two comics dalia and jeff
dye and they don't know the game like
dude we want to see him dustin poury i'm
like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa no you
don't understand man this kid it's a
marathon this is not a sprint it would
be such a disservice if they catapult
them even if i had a guy in the top 25
right now would not be fair to him he's
just
his his star power and the the
entertainment value yeah top five yeah
as far as his career
and the again the kudos to the ufc and
dana white especially what they're doing
with sugar shawn o'malley is how you
should be treating these guys boxing
does it really well where they bring
them up you know the right way let let
this kid grow into whatever he's going
to be but what you don't is want to
hinder the process
and toss them to the wolves man right
yeah you want to give him good stylistic
challenges at the right progressing
points in his career you know and it's
not as though the ufc has been perfect
in this situation you know i would go
back to jarrett cannonier who fought
clover to share a very early on in his
ufc career and i remember texting with
my friend ufc hall of famer joe silva
who had since left the company
and i believe he thought that was just
way too soon to give jared kane near
glover to share i could be mistaken but
i believe that was a mick maynard fight
that was made and how do you think jared
candidate would match up with glover to
share it today now granted they're in
different divisions but i think a lot
more favorably canonier just wasn't
ready for that type of challenge so i do
think thus far they've done a good job
with patty candidly as an mma fan you
know there's certainly going to be a big
segment of our fan base that roots
against paddy pimlet i would have liked
to have seen more resistance from kazula
vargas on the ground so i'm hoping that
whoever is next puts up a more
formidable challenge candidly than
vargas did against paddy pimlet this
weekend but you know i think a jim
miller might
jim miller fight you know maybe one or
two down i love that you know there are
things they can do with paddy pimlet but
he ain't a featherweight let's be clear
he's competing at 155 pounds and most of
the guys uh are bigger or stronger you
know and and to get to even to the top
10 at 155 you're walking through fire my
man it is
hands down the deepest most competitive
division all of mixed martial arts 55 in
the ufc you're walking through fire man
so
he has a tough task in front of him the
the only kind of caveat you know again
i'm not being negative on patty i do
think he's the real deal but if you
watch his first debut fight in ufc and
you watch this fight he does get hit
where it makes it exciting but there's
gonna be a certain level i was saying
before he came on to the guys here he
does get hit you know he he has been hit
in both fights it's a little alarming
you know if we want to compare him to
conor clearly not the
you know not the expert on the feet as
connor was and not as elusive and kind
of creative as connor but if you
remember connor coming up really didn't
get hit man and and patty will get hit
it's entertaining i like it but if
you're you know if patty's this you know
the stock that you're investing in it's
the one caveat and i'm sure his team
knows that too like hey man it's there's
been come a time where we don't want to
have this firefight we're getting hit
some of these more experienced guys are
really going to take advantage of that
no that's the truth and as a former pro
fighter obviously you can speak to this
you know some guys prioritize defense
and they sort of try to turn that
defense into offense look at a guy like
dominic cruz he treats your fists as if
they're swords right that they're gonna
literally cut his head off and then he
tries to sort of turn that movement and
that defense into his own offense you
know kenny florian has long said on our
podcast that striking defense is kind of
a lost art across the board in modern
day mixed martial arts i mean dan hooker
i think is a guy who's a good example of
somebody who he can take a shot but now
he's going to have to go back to the
drawing board having lost four or five
and he's going to have to raise his
guard and prioritize defense a little
bit i think the good news for patty is
that
you know when you can get touched and
win uh that's a good thing and i do
think he'll learn from that he certainly
hears the noise when it comes to that
but i do think he has to prioritize that
um because all it takes is one shot in
this sport and the whole narrative the
whole pendulum the whole career
trajectory swings uh with one left hand
but yeah i mean that's the only red flag
i see right now you know he seems to
have the right work ethic the right
discipline the right people around him a
lot of good early signs for paddy pimlet
for sure and that uh you know again
before coming out i was saying arnold
allen had a tough task against dan
hooker obviously dan hooker you know
taller ranger guy cutting down to 45 and
dan hooker mentioned how terrible the
weight cut was for him he said i've been
better off being drunk find that 55 i
would have felt better and probably
would have done better which is
hilarious i love dan hooker
you know but it's a tough task against
arnold allen who's won eight in a row
you know he's coming in there to to
fight dan hooker so
you know there's kind of this you know
paddy's the drug patty was by far the
biggest star in the card he's the one
everyone's waiting for he walks out
there's this huge reaction he obviously
gets the job done the crowd's going nuts
molly meatball comes out they're jumping
on the cage it's all this stuff
and then you gotta reset man and all
round has to walk out fighting this
monster dan hooker right and i was like
all right that's probably probably a
decision it's gonna be and dude i don't
know if it's the the the british fans
the o2 arena or whatever arnold allen
goes forget this noise i was like you
think that was a show peep this right
and just delivers five the night dude
one of the best rounds of the year
and it is crazy the juxtaposition right
between him and the liverpudlians right
like arnold allen walks out he's like a
certified public accountant he's coming
out so we will rock you you know i mean
like he should have been born in the
1960s and then obviously puts on an
absolute show but he's kind of fallen
under the radar and i think it kind of
dovetails with what we were talking
about earlier in terms of his career
progression you know the ufc has handled
him really well you know there were
times where he was in close fights and
you wonder kind of what we have here and
he wasn't putting guys away now all of a
sudden you look up he's won nine in a
row he's undefeated in the ufc and
systematically he's passing these
challenges at the right time and it
seems to me
even the bostonian in me right now that
he's ready for calvin kater in a main
event you know that was the fight he
called for and you know i'm happy for
ferrasa hobby i know i'm kind of going
off on a different direction here but
you know he has had some missteps with
other guys you know maybe guys haven't
you know fully realized their potential
under him even rory mcdonald or nasrat
hackbrast or other guys and now i really
feel like he has a guy uh in arnold
allen who's stealing in the ufc is
championship you know he's going to get
a title eliminator next and uh yeah i
really thought it was important for him
to shine and to as trite as it sounds
like when was style points on a show
that he was losing the spotlight um
several fighters on the prelims so i
thought he couldn't couldn't maximize
the showcase anymore yeah boy did he
answer the call and you know um one of
the downsides of doing the the fight
campaign shows is i don't hear the audio
i don't hear you guys talk because i
usually just do pay-per-view events so
it's usually you rogan and dc which
before he came on i think it's the
greatest combat sports analyst team
that's ever you know walked this earth
you guys are my favorite but i can't
hear
the your guys commentating that's one
downside of doing the show
so i you know i i in my head
you know and i'm not on social media
really so you tell me call out caving
kadar calvin kader i'm like oh my god
that's a freaking fight dude that is a
ridiculous fight yeah it makes sense and
it's funny you say that because
sometimes when i'm watching at home i
might be you know in my son's bedroom as
he's falling asleep and i'm watching on
mute without the commentators and
sometimes i'll find myself watching a
fight and i'm thinking man are they
calling this as if it's like the best
round of the year because you're sitting
here you know half baked in my son's
bedroom it looks like
2022 you know um but yeah man i mean i
think it's a good time for the
featherweight division i mean josh
emmett is lurking as well you know he's
a little bit long in the tooth and has
had a lot of injuries so i would like to
kind of see him get fast-tracked but
calvin kater doesn't have a fight you
know the belt in this division is going
to be on the line here in a couple weeks
but you know arnold allen is is going to
factor prominently in this mix and
candidly when you've got a nation behind
you you know that's not going to hurt
his cause in terms of getting big fights
no not at all and then we'll get off
this ufc london cards nuts after this
but the main event tom aspinall
going in this fight you know
it it's always tough you know there's a
time when you know there's pretenders
and contenders and for tom aspinall
you know
one fight went out of the first round
you know he went early in the second
round knocked the guy out in one of his
previous fights but he hasn't been a
world beater he hasn't been just like
just you know
fighting the the top tip of the spear
guys
so i i found an answer in the ufc goes
oh you're starching everybody here's
volkov who's really only been finished
three times his career
former m1 world champion bellator world
champion you know he went to a decision
against cyril gone the guy's a tough
customer man you you want to knock
everybody out here's volkov in o2 arena
dude and also tom aspinall is a covet
baby so he's been fighting
in front of 15 people so we talk about
ufc jitters
and he's never experienced that so
my only caveat going in the fight was
like huge tom fan it's a lot to bite off
man volkov in o2 arena he's fought there
before you know he's beat for doom he's
beat over him he's impossible to finish
here's tom asmral here's your moment
dude and it was there was so much on the
table for tom
and my god did this dude just completely
dominate and get an a-plus on his report
card for his introduction into the top
five into the ufc heavyweight division
yeah man no again you set it up well i
mean he literally changed his life that
night you know even if he loses his next
fight he has put himself just on a
totally different level with that
performance now aspinall was the
underdog when it opened and just because
he's the younger fresher faster more
prime fighter i was surprised by that
you know he did close as the favorite
yeah i just feel like there aren't a lot
of points of comparison for tom aspinall
in the heavyweight division right now
and as a former heavyweight yourself
with submission skills perhaps you're
the guy who can speak to this better
than anyone you know
some people have compared him to frank
mir you know i think he's a little
bigger than frank muir i think he's
faster than frank mir maybe he's not as
good with his offensive submissions
quite yet as frank mear in a mixed
martial arts setting you know um but
where's the point of comparison in
modern day mma the heavyweight right now
with the offensive submission skill set
that tom espinal does like curtis blades
is headlining this weekend he'll maul
the [ __ ] out of alexander volkov for 25
minutes but he can't necessarily find a
submission to save his life and i love
curtis you know but when i factored that
into the handicap i just thought tom
aspinall had a lot of ways to win but
how is he going to deal with the
pressure the stress of the moment i
think for him
you know in my last fighter meeting with
him it was more like a curiosity about
how he would handle the pressure than it
was in anxiety but he was so excited to
compete in front of fans and i thought
he he handled everything beautifully but
now i think you know that tom asmr can
be a ufc champion you really know the
way that he passed this test i think he
can and probably will be a champion in
the next three years i agree yeah i
co-signed on that you know when the
fight
kicked off i was like you know i was
telling my guys it's a tough fight for
asphalt man i'm rooting for him i want
to win i picked him to win but it's a
tough a tough go
and then within the first 45 seconds
when i saw the hand speed and the
difference in the quickness of tom and
his athletic ability i went oh top this
isn't getting out of the first round and
like what you can tell i'm like yeah man
volkov's in a world a world of problems
here this isn't going to end well for
volkov so you know i just thought it was
a coming out party for tom if if the
fans weren't familiar with them and you
know and he gets on the mic and
you know i was telling the guys before
he came on you know when when bisping's
in there doing the the in the ring uh in
the octagon uh you know interviews
you know bisbee was a guy who was never
shy you know he would call his shots and
i think he kind of brings that same
energy to the fighters and they feel
like all right here's biz being and
especially in o2 arena he's had some
historical fights there so i feel like
they kind of take on a bit of his kind
of character there and they're calling
guys out tom was ready to go man calls
out tied to avasa and in my head i'm
like oh my god when i didn't think this
guy could nail the knight any better he
calls out the perfect opponent right
number three heavyweight in the world
tied to avasa and i would assume and
you're betting man like me i'd assume on
the odds tom's a favorite in that fight
man yeah no and again i think you're
hitting on an interesting point that i
hadn't thought of in terms of people
feeding off of michael bisping's energy
because as i've told you before from the
time i first went in there to do my
first post flight interview in 2012 joe
silva said to me hey don't be afraid to
go in there and do my job for me if they
make a call out that makes sense i will
literally give them that fight and
obviously increasingly you've seen us
with a microphone pointing fighters in
that direction but i do think you've hit
on something there that i hadn't thought
of that they are feeding off of
bisping's energy and when you look at
tom aspell's number 11 in the world like
you're right tuivasa makes all the sense
in the world he's number three so for
tai obviously it's giving an opportunity
to a guy outside the top ten but i do
think aspinall would be favored and not
unlike guys like islam
and hamza maya you know i don't care
what numbers next to tom aspinall's name
how many heavyweights are you taking
right now seriously like i'm not this
isn't hyperbole like how many
heavyweights are you taking right now
over tom aspinall if you need a guy to
go beat francis in ghana like there
aren't that many like i can assure you
if you're giving me any welterweight in
the world right now to beat kamar usman
i'm saying hamza she might have been
there despite the fact that there are
eight guys ranked above him so if you're
telling me john to save a dog's life you
could have one heavyweight to go fight
in ghana and beat him who are you
sending in there it's either [ __ ]
stipe or tom aspen agree or john jones
because he hasn't completed but you're
absolutely right no i'm with you man
yeah i'm high on tom and i i don't know
who beats him i you know i would favor
him over cyril gone which is i know a
little bit crazy to say but after seeing
his performance
i don't you know he has all the skills
to get it done man um you know what i
want to see
yeah me too and i also think it's smart
on aspinol's uh kind of
process
because you know curtis blaze like you
said fights this weekend
stylistically
out of all the top five guys curtis
blades to me
you know it's not the most exciting
matchup it's probably the toughest
matchup for tom so if we can just
leapfrog that and go straight to tai
tuavasa who's third
all right let's let's let's deal with
that you know when the time comes but if
we can get that tied to a vasa fight
it's a fan favorite fight and then once
you beat him now you have some more
chips in your corner to go all right i
want to fight the winner of steep a john
you know
it's perfect no i mean an aspirin all
too evasive headliner makes all the
sense in the world and uh one thing i
will say about curtis blades who's 31
years old and headlining this coming
weekend he's not in any great rush in
terms of the championship and i know you
have a lot of connections with his team
um but he'll fight tom aspinall like
hers blades will fight everybody of that
i can assure you and i just would like
to see blades have this like
unabashed championship focus the way
like aspinall does you know and
when curtis has that he's one of the
best in the world so i'm excited to see
him on thursday and see where he's at
yeah he's a he's a tough dude to figure
out tough dude to beat you know it's
very rare he loses when he does you know
it's uh you know it's a francis or
something you know he hits clip but if
you don't get clipped you're it's a
rough night in the office against
because
man it's just a rough night in the
office speaking of heavyweight um you
know i chill on here two weeks ago and
we're talking about
the heavyweight division and you know we
both said it makes complete sense to do
jon jones stipe on that big july card
the international fight week that makes
all the sense in the world you have any
kind of
i don't even want to say prediction but
if john and stipe were to fight
you know what's your thoughts on that
it's a fascinating fight you know i
think size wise they would be pretty
comparable but jon jones would come in
the bigger man you know who knows with
stipe in terms of where he would be at
right we've seen him come in closer to 2
30 of late obviously his leanest version
was the one he presented the last time
out against daniel cormier but he's
fought once a year so who knows how he
would approach physically the jon jones
fight but i love the match-up i know
much of our fan base is kind of against
interim titles but i think given the
fact that ingano is likely to miss the
rest of the year throw an interim belt
on stipe and john
tuivasa and aspinall can compete on that
card as well which sets you up in a
little backup situation i mean seattle
gone is lurking but i think that
stipe would open as a betting favorite
against jon but it's a pick and fight to
me you know i could be off on that you
know i could be off on that i think you
were to open like plus 140 he would get
bet down close to even money i think
it's a pick and fight and i'm glad i
wouldn't have to make a prediction me
too yeah i think it's a pick em fight
because again to your point there's a
lot of x factors there what's steeping
come in as john we haven't seen that
heavyweight so that you know the
oddsmakers they really don't know either
so it's a pick-and-fight i do think
steve will be slightly favored just with
his history in the heavyweight division
but uh cheo was saying he spoke to
stipe's wife and stipe has put on what
he say 15 pounds of muscle like he's
he's big right now so he's used this
entire time just to kind of put on this
lean muscle to be a heavier guy
which to me can go one of two ways
sometimes all right cool man you'll be a
harder puncher but anytime you put on
more weight you're gonna be slower which
i think is one of it slower and your
stamina i don't care how you get it done
put on muscle there's no way you put on
muscle and you get better cardio they
just don't go hand in hand right so i
think that's one of stipe's biggest
assets is his cardio so i'm a little
alarmed when i heard he's put on weight
but you know he you know he knows what's
best for him i know john's put on weight
too which i
if i was in his camp i i i wouldn't
suggest it i think
his tools and his assets that
heavyweight come from his length his
speed his creativity if he wants to get
i think he's trying to get to 280 260
pounds it's like well now you're just
you're making it more even for you for
yourself
now you're gonna try to go toe-to-toe
with these real heavyweights and you're
gonna be slower to make a lot of sense
to me so
if there's so many x factors go in that
fight i just i just want to get
announced so we can just look forward to
that man i'm with you and i think for
stipe it does make sense
you know match up wise with francis and
ganu as the champion to probably be a
bigger heavyweight i do believe though
his best version is the
pound one that moved exceedingly well
the guy that faced daniel cormier it's
interesting too to talk to a guy like
derek lewis who isn't really in the
championship mix right now even though
he's highly ranked he has said like if
he's going to be a heavyweight champion
he's got to lose 45 pounds like before
he even begins his championship training
camp like he believes the championship
version of derrick lewis is 225 230 and
largely i think for jon jones at
heavyweight that's much more the
wheelhouse than building up to 270 and
cutting down you know um you see greg
hardy show up for fight week 291 pounds
it's like bro what are you doing you're
gonna get cut you know
yeah
that's what happened right
but uh yeah it it it the you know in
more power to them if they're teaming
them you want to figure it out and put
on weight or lose weight i just think
being the leanest best possible shape
your power's going to be there but
taking away your speed advantage whether
it's john or stipe is not the way to
handle it but they're going to figure it
out uh have you heard the rumblings
we're just going to cover everything
because i haven't talked in a while have
you you've heard the rumblings of connor
calling out camaro usman
yes
what's your thoughts on that because i
my initial thing was all right kind of
calls out everybody right calls out
everyone we're used to that
and then when dana was like i'm not
opposed to it
and then in my head you know obviously
conor is the biggest star we've ever had
in mixed martial arts so when he says
something there's there's definitely
some gravity towards it you know he's
definitely pulled off the floyd
mayweather fight and you know he hasn't
want to fight in quite some time but
you know when he does come back
you know he's put on this muscle i'm
sure you've seen him on instagram stuff
like that he again another guy's put on
muscle
the days of 145 are gone that's never
happening so at 55
he you know and he said you know i'll
take the winner of charles oliveira
versus justin gaichi in my head i'm like
yeah like they could do that with the
kumar usman the more i sit on it the
more i kind of chew on i'm like yeah
that'd be kind of cool especially for
kamar usman it's like you know he's
gonna fight leon edwards and leon
edwards deserves it more power to him
and no one's earned it more than leon
edwards you know but if camaro to get
past that for camaro it's kind of like
these super fights make sense this conor
is a super fight and for camaro he also
you know you saw him canelo which is
insane but you know i see what he's
doing there it's a muddy play but kamara
vs connor
yeah sign me up man sign me up well i
will say about dana and i know he was
criticized for even giving the charles
oliveira conor mcgregor fight any legs
but largely dana like does believe in a
meritocracy and in a perfect world like
the the number one contender would be
the guy challenging for the belt but
there are a lot of different factors you
know let's take charles oliveira before
i get to camaro right if he beats
justin gaichi right after what he did to
dustin poirier and michael chandler
would charles oliveira not be able to
call his shot and ask for the
seven figure payday that comes with
fighting conor mcgregor i guess on the
kamar usman side for me if kamza
chimayev is able to get past gilbert
burns and kamar usman is able to get
through leon edwards you know
usman and chimaya is the fight to make
and i think competitively i would think
that would be an itch that kamar usman
would want to scratch but yes you hit on
a lot of truths even if they're
inconvenient truths about conor mcgregor
and his star power and the payday that
kamar usman would realize i just think
for conor to wrap his head around like a
12-week commitment down to
pounds to fight charles oliveira is not
what he wants to do at this stage
you know 300
i also think too if you know the purest
out there i'm like no we have a ranking
system for a reason and the number one
contender should be fighting for the
championship i get all that but if
you're a fan of whoever that champion is
and you want them to get that [ __ ] you
money
connor is the only guy who gets him to
that point so
i'm a camaro fan so i want him to make
more money than god and that's why even
the canelo fight terrible fight for him
dude right awful
what canelo's in his prime to me the
pound for pound best in the [ __ ]
world he would absolutely mop the floor
with camaro i hope it happens so he gets
generational wealth right when when it
comes to conor it's like i hope that
happens so camaro gets this huge payday
that's why i want it and i know the
pirates are like well there's so many
contenders i get all that man but
kamara's put in the work where he
deserves this type of fight right and
he's beat most of the contenders right
and certainly there's some segment of
the fan base that still feels like hamza
chimaya has things to prove even if he
beats gilbert burns and takes his number
two ranking they're gonna be people who
think he needs one more win largely i
agree with you and a guy like charles
oliveira too um you know he does so much
good with the money right that how would
you not like that so they say to charles
you know hunter says all right charles
you can fight islam or conor mcgregor
you know i mean come on you know
it's a no-brainer man and yeah i know
fans get upset but it's like it's also a
business because when if if you're dana
white and you're sitting around on
monday's marketing meeting
and we're in the business of selling
pay-per-views and selling fights
you know it's like makachev you know or
you know conor mcgregor as much as i
love much of i do think he'd be you know
champ for a long time his time will come
but right now let's let's squeeze as
much green juice as we can out of conor
whether it's at 55 or 70. i don't care
but let's make one of these fights
happen even for a world championship and
i'll just say this right my former boss
bellator ceo bjorn rebny right in 2009
when he launched bellator right and
bjorn at that time was like the biggest
ufc fan i had ever met in my life oh wow
i didn't know he loved mixed martial
arts
but his number one goal was just to try
to take sort of that promotional
component out of it and make it a
meritocracy and make it a bracket and
it's just so much easier said than done
you know it really is and i feel
entertainment
yes at the end of the day it is and i do
think that by and large the ufc does a
great job giving the most deserving guys
those opportunities
but gosh there's so many factors like
even the calendar be right like even
just the calendar for usman and edwards
like everything has to align and if it
doesn't um sometimes to stay relevant
you need to take a fight and candidly i
think for conor he's going to have to
take a fight because the welterweight
championship is not going to be the one
that gets presented you know yep agree
are you uh are you on are you as high on
hamza as uh the rest of the world dude
when i say that i've been on hamzat
dagger standing in a nut for quite some
time bro i mean you you that dude scares
me man scared and that and just it it's
he's become like this mythical creature
like darren till's training with him and
chael said he watched him train at the
the ap
you know in in vegas at the ufc
institute and he's like dude i'm telling
you man these stories and
his coach coach told me this in sweden
he goes we've never seen him lose a
round i go yeah but don't you have like
latifi and gustafin he goes yeah
he's never lost around
what
well right what well like what are you
supposed to think right when you hear
that he tosses alir latifi who's
competing at heavyweight this weekend on
his head when comsat's now fighting
gilbert burns who
i mean i work with gilbert burns as
coaches down here at the institute of
human performance they say he's as
strong as he's ever been he's like it's
like a lightweight fight of light
heavyweight right like i mean i hey
gilbert burns is a [ __ ] dog man you
know and it wouldn't necessarily
surprise me to see him drag homs out
into deep water but i am
all chips to the center of the table on
hamzad and i've seen him fight live
several times right so i think i'm even
like more all about it you know and more
trying to fast track him you know i said
going into 2021 that my dream fight for
that year in any weight class was hamza
chimaev against colby covington and it's
still a dream fight for me um but i
don't know i really really can't wait
till we get to april 9th to truly see
how hamza does against an elite
welterweight with respect to lee jin
liang that's the thing right it's like
can we not [ __ ] all over lee jin liang
and gerald murshart right i mean come on
you know april 9th we're getting clarity
though we're getting so much clarity and
i think it's gonna relieve some of the
you know the hate that hamzak gets from
the pure stuff like that and when i
heard the gilbert burns match up
and i love i listen i i was training
with gilbert at the black zillions in
florida uh when i was getting ready to
fight nogara in brazil and he was just
into mma but he was the jitsu coach and
he is the nicest guy you've ever met
he's like such a sweet human being i
absolutely love gilbert
i and this is no shade on gilbert
because he you know he's he's one of the
top five in the world for a reason you
know he did rock kamar hussman he's a
savage
i don't see in any facet that he beats
hamza that's how positive i am of hamza
being like the next freaking thing man
yeah no i mean we are aligned you know i
think a lot of these divisions have like
a man right now whether it's kamza
chimaya or islamakashev you know marab
dwalish willy is not as skilled as those
guys but he's a guy at bantamweight
who's in the top six who i think most of
the strikers in that division are going
to try to avoid um yeah gilbert's the
man and i think his biggest asset going
into that fight is that he has all the
self-belief in the world and it's not as
though he
doesn't agree with the superlatives
about khan zach he just thinks he's
better and he's gonna beat him you know
and i love that about gilbert but man
it's like you know this guy was in there
and getting knocked out by dan hooker in
2018 with all due respect i just see
this candidly brian brennan as two guys
in different weight classes you know and
my concern which he might have long term
was
can he make 71 consistently and it
actually looks like he's going to be
able to do that you know so
and my and to your point too like one of
the fights you want to see most is kobe
versus hamzat
i think there's a world because to me
nothing is better than a fighter's come
up like when when they're just starting
to go through the rankings and there's
kind of that weird mystery like can they
pass this test can they do this there's
nothing more exciting in sports than
watching an actual contender become a
world champion when they pass those
tests like conor mcgregor his come up
was insane dude and that's why i'm such
a big ride-or-die conor mcgregor fan his
antics outside that gun it's getting a
little crazy i still defend the guy but
the the come-up of the like these
superstars there's nothing better so for
hamzat
i would like to see him fight camaro and
again
i might be in this weird hamza trance i
just don't see camaro beating him which
is insane he's the pound for pound
number one guy on the on the roster in
the ufc
but i you know if he beats gilbert and
let's say he molly wops in the first
round which could happen
i still don't think he goes straight to
camaro i i think you give him the kobe
fight if he if he gets out there
uninjured then we go colby and then it's
very clear who's next for for camaro if
he were to get past leon edwards yeah
yeah no i think that makes all the sense
in the world i mean like think about
hamza chimayo have been there with like
yuri prohaska or glover to share you
know like those aren't like huge
mismatches necessarily and we're talking
about the elite 205 pounders 35 pounds
up you know so i'm excited to see him
toe to toe with gilbert burns like in
the octagon on saturday night not
necessarily in the lead up but like once
they've rehydrated what do those two
guys look like what do they weigh in at
you know does gilbert burns re-weigh at
you know 78 and hamzad at like 202. i
mean
you know so yeah i mean i think an usman
fight has the potential to just be an
absolute bloodbath war just one of the
most exhausting nights of both of those
men's professional lives um but it's
exciting man you know it's like it's
always interesting when people say oh
you know what where are the superstars
and it's like dude they're always coming
i remember a few years ago it's like
well maybe this guy out of sonya can
take the torch and sure as [ __ ] he took
it you know what i mean so like there's
always new superstars and you're right
like the most special part of the job
for me without question is the come up
like people ask me all what's the best
fight you've ever called and it's more
about the moments when jan blehovich
breaks through for poland and becomes a
first-time champion or shara or charles
oliveira um the progression to become a
ufc champion and i think that's why like
tom aspinall's performance put me in
such a good mood me too
sort of you know seems like we're
watching a guy you know on route to
greatness made my night and i i think uh
we'll get off homs out of this i do
think there's a world where hamza could
get the 170 pound
uh world championship and also you know
we've just talked about how big he is
him versus izzy
you know that's not too far off man
yeah that could happen this weird world
of the ufc that we live in yeah the one
thing that i find most interesting about
chimayab is that he wants to be fighting
a lot more often than he is being
allowed to compete and that's twofold
right part of it is because it's hard to
get people to fight him but it's also
because
andreas michael and the coaches at his
gym like they want him to be clear in
tension they don't want him flirting
with middleweight super fights every
other week they want him focused on
welterweight title contention and
sometimes that's going to mean sitting
for six or eight months but you can be
sure like if he beats gilbert burns on
april 9th like he ain't going to take
the rest of the year off waiting for the
winner between kamar hussman and leon
edwards like dude wants to fight and
as you know when you get to the elite
levels like you can't just fight every
few weeks so i think they're gonna
figure out that navigation
yeah that's why you know i and to your
point too i suggested a kobe comet and
fight to close the year out let's keep
him active let him take out these big
dogs you know that's a great fight
um before i get you out of here
you know with when rogan uh missed the
uh the pay-per-view um
how how was that for you because again i
think what makes you rogan and dc
special
it's similar and i'm not saying we have
the same jobs in any capacity you know
on the last companion we talked about
octopus for 30 minutes but with what you
guys do and all the research and all
that what makes you guys
hands down the best ever do it is is
there's this companionship it's friends
it's friendship you guys have fun you
guys know exactly you know you don't
talk over each other you set each other
up it's like this friendship that i
think shows on the broadcast which you
know sometimes it's just a job and you
have you know your play-by-play you have
your color commentator and you know and
then the guys do their thing it's great
there's nothing wrong with that but when
the three of you get together there's
this weird kind of chemistry that i
think everybody vibes with so when you
take that out and you know you put in
business who's fantastic he's amazing i
think he's you know definitely going to
be you know the face of the ufc as far
as commentating goes uh if rogan would
ever stepped out he's the next guy in
line but
it has to be a little hard for you right
like going through that dynamic and
that drama and stuff like that
yeah i mean and i appreciate everything
you say sincerely and i do think the
reason your content does so well is
because it's relatable and people just
enjoy every one of these dynamics that
you have wisely put yourself in but yeah
it looked like joe was gonna work the
show so i was massively disappointed
when he decided that he wasn't gonna
work the show and candidly he's as
selfless as it gets that's the thing
right it's like he took himself out of
that show because every single time he
would have gone to the octagon they
would have been chanting for joe rogan
every single fighter who the focus is
supposed to be on would have got on the
mic and put joe over and he just didn't
want to i think be a distraction and be
the center of attention but there's just
a special dynamic to that broadcast
booth when he is there and you know he's
as irreplaceable as it gets in a
broadcasting field in which we are all
replaceable you know there's just not
another joe rogan walking through that
door and even though i have said at long
last that i think that he will outlast
me in the ufc broadcast booth like i
think he's a life or i think he'll he'll
do that job forever i don't think so
well we'll see we'll see i guess i just
see him on fight night you know and i
just see the joy that it brings him and
of all the things that he has his toe in
i think that he
he just gets so much joy from it but i
could be wrong you know i just could
never imagine ufc pay-per-views without
him and obviously there's just a special
component that he brings to that booth
that um that nobody else can really
bring so yeah it was a tough fight week
but um i had never been so excited to
give him a hug in my life obviously when
he was back with us a couple of weeks
ago and uh obviously we're thankful to
have him in jayville here in a few weeks
man yeah and i i feel like when i see
the three of you together it has that
big fight energy when i see the three of
you i'm like oh this is a big boy card
let's go man well thank you for the
three of you guys man it's great it's
crazy to think we've been doing it now
for five years i remember when i called
my first fight with joe 10 years ago in
2012 on short notice because goldie
couldn't make it for whatever reason and
now i was looking today just i was
looking today to see the last time we
were in columbus ohio and it's like man
you know we've been doing these
pay-per-views five and a half years
together and um you know i just want
those guys to have fun and be loose and
um hopefully we succeed more than we
fail
oh man you guys have been crushing uh
also dc such as a special dude you know
me and dc did this super ball companion
on thick boy and you know me and dc have
been friends for years man and training
partners we have all these stories but
you know we haven't seen each other for
a long time sure as hell haven't worked
together
but it's just like he just such a you
know open-minded like fun dude so me and
him are laughing non-stop during this
freaking broadcast man i mean just could
not stop laughing man he's just like a
guy it's like you're in the locker room
and dc's the funniest guy in the locker
room man no it's true man i mean he's
probably the most naturally gifted
broadcaster that i've ever worked with
you know the first time i saw him on
television in 2011 i was in the delivery
room with my wife and it was the first
espn mma live show that i ever missed
and daniel was doing his first like
national tv show and i was like yeah i
mean his suit is like five sizes too big
but this is really tough like he just
was great and he is great and candidly
for me he's my brother like and i'm sure
you can relate to this like we're not
always like this right like there are
times where we have gotten into fights
and had disagreements and
but i love him like a brother and i just
can't help but smile and be happy when
i'm around him you know like he just has
this energy that is indescribable and uh
i know i talk about rogan in these
glorifying special terms but dc's really
right there man i mean when he's not in
the booth we miss that too like you you
feel that lack of cormier presence when
he's not there no you guys are the ufc
rat pack you know you can't
it's not the pack if one's missing man
you know we need the three of you
together for it to be a big event before
i get you out here
tell the fans why they should tune into
this fight night in columbus on saturday
i mean solid main event you know but
it's like you know you look at the card
from top to bottom and i know i know you
work for the ufc you know it's not going
to blow your hair back you know so
yeah i mean certainly the main event i
think has been heightened by what tom
aspinall did last week and i'm not sure
if curtis blades and chris dawkis would
sort of subscribe to that line of
thinking but
if they're watching the shop show like
let's [ __ ] go boys right you saw what
the number 11 guy did last week you know
huge opportunity now to do something
just as special you know so i'm excited
for that and obviously matt brown you
know hasn't competed in ohio since his
win over eric silva in the main event in
cincinnati in 2014
i mean he's 41 years old and i mean i
don't know that anybody sort of can you
know light up the ohio crowd quite like
matt brown so i'm excited that he's
healthy and uh and he's on the main card
max griffin and neil magney got a big
flyweight eliminator with ascar askarov
and kaikada france so yeah i mean the
ufc cuts my check so i can get excited
about you know the worst ufc fight night
of the year but this is certainly not
that and uh i'm excited to get to
columbus man well i love it man good
luck out there and uh we'll be watching
i think uh i'll be on the road in
chicago but i have the fights on in the
back
and uh
yeah man you know you know i love you
man we and
your schedule's busier than mine man so
i'm always like hey come to a food truck
or get on a companion but you're busy
man you got kiddos but we got to figure
some some way to get you out here get
you on a food truck or a fight companion
man dude i would love to do a companion
or a food truck i was waiting for you
guys to give sneakers to every guest
before i did the food truck thing and
now that you're giving sneakers away i
think i'll make the plunge no but dude
we're at the top of my list the next
time i get to southern california and
keep up the great work i'm ingesting
everything you guys are doing and uh i
appreciate you having me my man thank
you brother appreciate man have fun this
saturday say what's up
kenny for me man kenny floyd i miss that
guy i mean him used to do a lot of work
out here then he moved i know pandemic
so all my friends have left me man so
tell kenny i said what's up man all
right buddy keep up the good work thanks
again for having me we'll talk hi
brother talk later all right jim what do
you got how great is john anakin he's
the best dude one of my favorite people
in all sports and the best at his job
too he's incredible he doesn't mess up
at all never mess up
he was saying makchev's name different
and he definitely knows
[Music]
yeah
yeah i mean
i would get fired from the ufc just
because i struggle with names especially
all the dagger standings i know it's
getting tougher and tougher these days
oh my god dude we're gonna have to adapt
we're gonna have to adapt just go you
know just come hams out he would give
his whole name like all right be quit
trying to flex on me dude just that
daddy like you said and then mock
chevy's saying is certain like i forget
chef or something
yeah all right dude be cool man
all right jim what do you got all right
first one is this is a israel assassin
israel arasana on his youtube channel he
was watching the london fights and then
he noticed that darren till jumped on
the cage with tom aspinall so this is
what he said
[Music]
no one ever
[Music]
yes the [ __ ] off
[Music]
so he's basically clowning him for
jumping on the cage with tom so then
darren tell responded as well uh see
tilt seems to have taken offensive
especially part where they last say he
hasn't won in a while let him enjoy it
and he put at style ben and you idiot
tom asmal asked me to get on the cage
with him keep looking down on me for my
losses brother it's all good i'll be
here one day you watch you haven't
looked the best either in your last few
fights
staff cocaine is not healthy for
fighters interesting
yeah never heard that rumor but yeah i
don't yeah that's not easy's thing you
know yeah
you know uh darren tail like stuck a lot
of [ __ ] so you know it seems like he's
getting a little better now but we'll
see
yeah well i think it's tough because if
you're not winning the [ __ ] talking of
course
yeah
uh this i thought was interesting
because hamza remember
you told that story when hamzat flew to
freaking island to beat up connor so now
he's asking connor if he wants to train
with him
i love that yeah he's just creating a
whole freaking
crew with him
um
yeah you know and obviously jeff die and
crystalia don't know ufc very well but
on uh the fight campaign jeff dice said
this he goes man if if i'm uh
conor mcgregor i take comms out under my
wingman or like a paddy pimple under my
wing and like hey let's let's you know
let me show you like let me help you
he's like that
makes sense because like comes on connor
never fight that's never happened
there's no threat there so it'd be cool
if connor tyler's just a different
animal though i don't think he's gonna
go there to maybe a train but you know
he's just a different animal yeah
um
okay this is also kind of weird
so sean strickland for some reason he
has beef with khalil roundtree and he
went off on went off on him on his
instagram i believe
really
so uh we had cleo roundtree on food
truck it uh airs on wednesday so the
food truck cleo round tree you'll see
he's just a great freaking dude yeah
that's my favorite people across the
board everyone says he's great
except for sean strickland he goes you
guys have no idea who this man is i'm
telling if you met him you would
absolutely hate him i disagree with that
you want to hear some time i smarted
around chad bled him up while laughing
the entire time that was the last time
he sparred me even apologized just
because he was uh a decent body he still
wouldn't
all right go ahead
round trip because clearly you guys have
no idea where the [ __ ] this man is and
i'm going to explain to you who this man
is and all you little little [ __ ]
saying oh we'll go spar him you guys
understand that we used to trade the
same gym and i would have loved to use
him as a body i only got the opportunity
once and then he would avoid me like the
plague i wanted you i tried to
but anyways back to why you guys have no
idea who the [ __ ] little round tree is
there's this chick you big girl big tall
little thick a little bit too thick for
me but 20 pounds lighter she looked like
a [ __ ] supermodel anyways amazing
sweet girl
clue walks up behind her to like show
her move and she makes like a sexual
harassment joke and it was [ __ ]
hilarious i laughed the gym laughed and
then cleo [ __ ] snaps on i'm like dude
like this is like a it's like a sweet
girl like she's [ __ ] joking calm down
anyway seconds
we're all training i'm giving everybody
a speech about like when you're on the
mat you need to go the best [ __ ]
trying to take his head take his spot
and i looked and i pointed at cleo and i
was like if i see you guys going [ __ ]
round tree i know you're being a bunch
of [ __ ] because he's the softest guy
on the map
this guy [ __ ] storms off the gym gets
a little emotional or like the third
time
i uh
actually the third time the third time i
had to be a little [ __ ] up
he had this ex-girlfriend once and i
joked i was like i hate on her too and
you were the better man you know but it
was funny it was like it was like me and
your boys you know it was like
camaraderie and he goes to ufc and
[ __ ] complains like this this man is
a cut you guys have no concept who he
none of that stuff shows that cleel's a
bad guy
it's funny when he says that that's why
yeah it's just like you're kind of a
douche yeah yeah yeah it was a hard take
yeah
only got 45 000 views mm-hmm
yeah you know fighters are gonna fight
you know it's you know what can you do i
i like sean strickland and i like khalil
but i know khalil way better than sean
stricken khalil's a good dude yeah great
guy i mean everyone thinks so
um
okay so this is just chelsea's opinion
that otasana needs to fight colby
cummingson
and go up to 85.
i think he needs to go up to 85. the
kobe has called out three guys in the
last two weeks he of course called up
kamaru spain he called it israel he
called out doesn't pray i've got to
understand the one thing those three
guys have in common is they're all world
champions
um they're hard call outs by chaos by
cass who's obviously a number one
contender
uh does not get a fight for a
championship it's a tough spot so he's
saying look i'm even willing to leave
the division let me take this goal and
take it off number one contender let me
cash it in at 185.
quite frankly nobody needs uh kobe as
bad as izzy i don't know if israel is
aware of that yet but he's trying to
fight people that aren't doing their job
in the media that aren't bringing the
attention that aren't helping the brand
and making the marquee fight as big as
it could be i think if izzy stood back
and saw what colby has to offer that's
gonna be a partner that you would like
to do business with agree
agree
yeah there's there's not much um
that's gonna get you up for an izzy
fight right now it's not because of izzy
you just need a formal opponent like
jose aldo forever was the king of
division really didn't get his notoriety
to [ __ ] conor mcgregor so
not that izzy needs more notoriety but i
think to
really get the the casuals to rally
around and uh you know pay money to
really make a difference for his fight
colby could be that guy he's your
huckleberry
yeah that'd be a cool fight to watch too
um so just a quick one francis degano
got his surgery it was successful
without nine weeks uh nine months nine
months yeah holy months
yeah rematch roseanne mcgenis versus
carlos esparza for ufc 274. okay carla
juan last time yep
and rose be a slight favor in that fight
now
this is i don't know if this is a joke
or not but peorian says that sean
o'malley will be in his corner because
his guys can't make it because of you
know travel and stuff yeah that's cool
i dig that
and he asked senator henry cejudo as
well so you're just going for
the celebrity
monster mma corner
and that shot is taken by sugar shawn
hilarious
i love that
you already talked about um
arnold allen versus cater right with uh
johnny i love that fight yeah because
you know i can't hear the broadcast so i
didn't know he called calvin keller out
that is a freaking fight man
do you know this guy casey lydon he
works for mma fighting he's also married
to esther lin that photograph oh yeah
photographer yeah great guy so he's been
with me fighter for a long time he's
like 44 years old he had his first mma
fight and he won
so he he what he did is he did my boy
rich child's thing
where oh that one yep bullies or what's
it called uh i think it's called ulta
now he changed the name but it's from i
think what it was from something wimps
to yeah webster warriors
warriors what they changed to ulta
so what this program does
is you do a 20-week fight camp with like
a major major gym yeah like some of the
biggest gyms like for us
um john kavanagh
you know greg jackson you you go to
actual camps you get 20 weeks
you have you don't have to have any
prior knowledge of fighting and they
mold you in 20 weeks you do a real camp
like an actual professional mma fighter
for 20 weeks and then 20 weeks you don't
have to but if you want you can take a
smoker where you fight another person
with the same experience that's pretty
cool pretty cool man and you get to real
like kind of check that off the bucket
list that you got to
go through a training camp and take on a
fight and it's pretty cool man it's so
that's he won esther's
esther's uh husband one yeah as a
journalist too that's cool he's an anime
journalist so he actually stepped in the
k or stepped into whatever that is yeah
more power too man good for him yeah his
wife esther's you know amazing yeah yeah
one of the most talented we've ever seen
all right so we have some fights we have
ufc and one championship
yeah so you have uh a fight night in uh
columbus ohio and john anak built that
guys up for you broke it down a little
bit you got uh dukakis and doncastacus
yeah you got chris dawkis and curtis
blades for your main event
you know chris coming off the knockout
of um
derek lewis and then obviously curtis
blades is just one of those guys he's
always going to be floating around the
top five for as long as he's fighting
um
you know
uh ask rob versus kai kara france
probably your best fight on the card on
the lineup you look at it latifi olinyx
fun my boy neil magni
max griffin how neil magney's on the
main card is nutsos to me but it is what
it is
neil magnus uh hoping to take the hamzap
fight but hamza got gilbert burns a nice
fight max griffin which is a great fight
um matt brown versus our boy brian
barbarina that's a great fight matt
brown i'm sure he's gonna blow the roof
off uh you know the ohio fan base there
it's a good card it's a good card
compared to the fight night london not
the same vibes
but you know
whether it's bellator ufc whatever you
watch nobody has a better card than one
championship this weekend one
championship has a hell of a card for
you guys it's this saturday march 26th
for people in north america it will be
available at 1am eastern time on
pay-per-view but i'm telling you this
card is stacked from top to bottom
i have a really special interest in it
uh because one of my boys john wayne
park yeah it's his last fight it's a
muay thai legends fight um
i'm praying to god he wins this fight if
he wants his fight to be his 100th win i
think is that right
john wayne parr man one of the best ever
do it you met him in australia
incredible dude the nicest guy ever man
just uh walking legend man so it's his
send-off fight so that's really why i
want to focus on this card you also got
two people that we talk i would say a
lot about throughout the history of you
know whether it's uh the big brown
breakdown or below the bell or to the
shop show or fight companies with rogan
or fight pains in general that i do now
cod best fight companion you got the i
think
the most stylish
best-looking body in mixed martial arts
sexy yamaha
freaking thing you say angela no no sir
no sir sexy how you know my vibes dude
you got sexy yama with just that golden
skin dude he is jack city so you got the
mma japanese legends fight against uh
aoki who is obviously uh basically an
anaconda disguised as a small japanese
man
um and then you also got uh ruditang
versus dj who obviously dj is considered
one of the best if not the best mixed
martial artist of all time and dj's over
that one championship what's great about
this fight
is there's no judges so there's not
going to be a decision
so it's four rounds
and they're in mma gloves the entire
time but the first round the the
gentleman that he's fighting
uh ruetang is literally a compo you got
to look this guy up he is a complete
monster might have the best chin you've
ever seen i saw him get head kicked and
just kept look at him he puts his hands
down he's the most entertaining fighter
that you you've ever seen it he just
puts his hands down and goes to work
um you can see on youtube it's almost at
10 million views rooting those savage
moments it's insane dude he just this
little monster
so clearly muay thai's his thing he's an
absolute uh
complete monster when it comes to muay
thai so he's fighting demetrius johnson
dj so what they're doing is the first
round is just muay thai with mma gloves
on the second round is mma the third
round is muay thai the fourth round is
mma and there's no judge's decision you
know it's just i guess a draw if nobody
gets finished
with my mixed martial arts experience
i would uh be willing to bet that dj
finishes him in the second round i think
he chokes him out in the second round i
think he takes it down chokes him out
and i know routang you know he's doing
some jiu jitsu and wrestling in thailand
so but
you're literally messing with the the
best that would do it as far as from
striking to wrestling to grappling it's
it's there's there's not a there's not
enough hours in the day to make up the
difference of trying to adapt to that
grappling i think dj gets a submission
victory i'll say rear naked choke or arm
bar in the second round i do think you
know that first round's gonna be a bit
of a demon for him to get out of um but
i do think with his footwork his
movement he can move enough where he
doesn't get finished but come that
second round all he has to do is get a
leg
and it's over so i think uh dj wins that
fight by submission
second round but that fight is so
interesting
and then obviously the best fight in the
card is the adam weight championship
uh the the women's adam weight
championship the one championship adams
uh
championship against angela lee and i
think the best name in uh mixed martial
arts
sports
yeah so you're showing andrew lee right
now who is a complete demon i think her
dad was an anaconda her freaking
uh jiu jitsu is second to none she's not
bad on the feet at all she can obviously
carry herself on the feet but really her
kind of specialty what makes her the
outlier is her jujitsu and
also not mad easy on the eyes as well
super marketable and uh also has that
mom power as well has the mama power her
husband uh i think is also a fighter but
also her brother
also fights and her sister and her
sister the whole family fights yeah
but she is a complete badass man
but when she's going against stamp and
what's inside stamp stamp won the grand
prix to earn this title shot uh but you
know stamps background is muay thai
she's also pretty damn good at jiu jitsu
too
you know when you watch uh angela lee's
fights
you know she has a tremendous chin she's
fought world championship boxes before
she's taking crazy punches you know and
just keeps doing the damn thing finally
gets them down and submits them
you know so i i think she's gonna
definitely stamps can have an advantage
on the feet with her muay thai but again
i think it's only a matter of time and
stamps young she is you know uh she's
gonna be your champion but i just think
angela hill uh uh anjali is too much
right now for her because you know stamp
will go to the ground and uh you know
she's won some pretty big competitions
as far as ju jiu jitsu goes but uh
angela is just an outlier man when it
comes to ground you know she's trained
with uh aoki she's a freaking badass man
her transitions she's super creative
like aoki if something's there she's
gonna take it it's hard to train for
that type of ground game man she's very
creative super super creative
and then you guys you guys always forget
she has that mama power man so that's
going down saturday march 26th one
championship my boy
freaking john wayne parr on his freaking
retirement fight a hundred fights if he
wins this bad boy 100 fights they have
the japanese legends uh aoki vs sexy
yama sexiyama best body in the history
of mixed martial arts
and then you got dj versus rutang doing
the special fight four rounds mma gloves
one round muay thai sorry two rounds are
gonna be muay thai two rounds gonna be
mma i think dj gets it done and then my
favorite fight on the card the women
headline this thing angela lee for stamp
fairtax and i think anjali gets it done
via submission so i will take uh angelia
via submission oh
dj via submission and then i will also
take my boy john wayne park getting it
done via ko tko however you want to see
fit there
and then uh
aoki uh
sexy an interesting one because when you
watch uh sexy yama just kind of doing
his thing you know he'll do some
commentating stuff just
i mean i don't know who his
stylist is but jesus christ dude just a
dime piece man just a straight up dying
piece
look at him
look at him dude
look at that watch i don't know what
that is the thing i know with
water i don't know what it's like he's
representing that watch company though
but he's a very stylish man oh my god
best fashion in mma dude best fashion
like dude usually her that many
bracelets unless you're a chris angel i
say it's frowned upon but sexy i'ma can
he can literally do whatever he wants
yeah he's
distractingly good looking distracting
dude and do you want to talk about his
lats daddy and his lower back don't get
me started and his golden skin look at
this there you go look at him dude
what is happening right now
and it's here like that silver here
wispy dime piece
tough fight against aoki you know he's
definitely longer in the tooth there
very tough fight against aoki to not get
submitted
but uh you know i i'm not going to pick
against my boy sexy helmet it ain't
happening is he going to win i wouldn't
put money on it but i'm not been against
them
but there you have it that's one
championship it's going down this
saturday by far the best freaking card
of the weekend
it's the best card in a long time as
well whether no matter what organization
that you watch one championship is
delivering some real
real entertaining stuff right now man so
again that is saturday march 26th
available on pay-per-view starts at 1
a.m eastern so is that 10 p.m pacific
not sure it's on pay-per-view but again
you got angela lee you got stamp fair
tax best name in combat sports you got
rue tang uh dj dj the pound for pound
i mean top two greatest of all time and
again you got uh aoki and sexy yama and
then we kick it off with my boy john
wayne parr going for it for his 100th
win you guys owe it to him to tune in to
watch john wayne parr in his send-off
fight man so enjoy those fights one
championship pay-per-view
that 1am eastern go watch it it's a hell
of a card man it's a hell of a card
is that it chin that's it
uh i will be in frickin chicago this
week i'm chicago please send your
recommendations for deep dish pizza even
though i won't eat it the rest of the
team well but i will watch them eat it i
guess just as much joy watching people
eat it um no i will probably try it out
but uh yeah that's this thursday friday
saturday chicago it's actually
schaumburg improv right outside chicago
but go get your tickets right now
chicago i got the flyest outfit you've
seen for chicago i get this ridiculous
jacket for you guys cubs inspired uh
that is march 24th through 26th that's
this week thursday friday saturday
before i head off to chicago this
wednesday is shaub and friends at the
hollywood improv one show one night only
8pm we've got crystalia jeff dye brian
callan chappelle lacy and a very special
guest you know how we do this be our
seventh sold out show in a row so la
come get some at the hollywood improv
this wednesday 8pm one show only but
chicago europe this week thursday friday
saturday then after that april 14th
through the 16th i might stand up live
in phoenix arizona
and then austin texas is i guess mid end
of april austin texas your boy is one of
the headliners for the moon tower comedy
festival which is a very big deal for
your friend here man i work very hard in
stand-up and for them to invite me to be
a headliner is a big deal so that's a
special uh weekend for me that's april
22nd and april 23rd at cap city in
austin texas the new cap city they've
redone it new ownership brand new place
it's gonna be lit that thing will sell
out any day now we're already halfway
sold out so go get tickets right now uh
thickboy.com or fatkz.com that's the
moon tower economy festival in austin
texas
also that same week i have a huge
announcement that i will announce very
soon here so uh yeah la you're up
wednesday chicago thursday friday
saturday uh thick mudder is april 9th at
10 30 a.m we have a 5k and a 15k to
offer you guys so if you don't want to
go through the whole
15k
do the 5k guarantee whatever physical
shape you're in you can finish both of
them if you go to toughmudder.com sign
up for the 10 30 a.m thick mudder if you
use the promo code thick boy you get 10
off which it actually is a lot of money
off to run that race and if you're
looking uh if you order now you can
still get the thick mutter shirt just in
time it's literally just for this thick
mutter event april 9th
um go to thickboy.com we just dropped
new shirts and hoodies there as well you
guys have seen me wearing them it's the
dark blue the black and the
the kelly green thick boy hoodie but the
thick mudder tee is available right now
for you guys go to sickboy.com
tuffmutter.com and click on the 10 30
a.m race april 9th in san bernardino
california
and come run with the boys man the whole
squad will be there man it's one of my
favorite things to do on this planet so
come on out it's a grand old time
chicago see this week thank you guys for
watching shout out to john anak one of
my favorite people in the business and
that's it man stay safe be nice to each
other have fun stay thick chicago see
you soon i'm out